- I'm ready for this.
("Have a Goon One" by
Warner/Chappell Productions)
- Right now we're at
Stronghold Bouldering,
we're about to do some rock
climbing, or bouldering.
- Nobody else was around
except for Ryan and Shane,
so I'm here as a Test Guest,
or a guestie, if you will.
- I've climbed a whole bunch of ladders,
whole bunch of stairs.
Vertical ascension, I'm pretty good at it.
I don't know about this though.
- We're all also trying to see who can
climb the wall the fastest.
I see Jordan right there behind camera.
If I can beat her I'll be happy
because she's a Megatron.
- I don't think I'm scared of heights.
I'll find out when I get to the top.
- The boys are already gonna
hurt themselves behind you.
What makes a good rock climber?
- You want to try and use
your legs as much as you can.
- Okay.
- You're gonna get the most
strength from your legs.
- Really?
- People forget that a lot.
(cheery music)
- Who do you think is
gonna do the best here,
Gumby, Xena, or me?
- It's hard to say.
- Why do you not get a weird nickname?
- Okay, Dopey, how about Dopey?
- That's a good one.
(violin music)
- [Ryan] Look at his legs.
- [Jordan] He's like a
little spider monkey.
- I don't know where my
little feet are going.
- [Jordan] Look how long his legs are.
- [Ryan] This isn't
fair, he has spider legs.
- [Jordan] He needs to
get a height handicap.
- [Shane] No, no, no.
- Ryan and I need a height handicap.
- I worked very hard to be this tall.
(orchestral music)
- Ahh, done.
What'd I get get?
How'd I do?
- I stopped at 19.46, when
you were right around there.
- 19.46, I beat Shane.
(Dark orchestral music)
- [Jordan] Woah Ryan.
- [Shane] Ryan.
10.7.
- 10 seconds!
- I'd like to thank my mom, my dad
for helping me get to this moment.
- Ryan is secretly an expert rock climber.
- Shane and Jordan for being inferior.
("Have a Goon One" by
Warner/Chappell Productions)
- This is probably the
hardest bouldering one,
or one of the harder ones.
And we're gonna end poorly.
- Ouch! (laughs)
- That went great, it was a lot of fun.
This is definitely something I can
see myself doing in the future.
- Right now my forearms and
my hands are very tired.
- I did about as well as I expected.
I succeeded on a few them,
and then on the other
ones I just fell off.
Sometimes it's a choice.
(Jordan laughs)
- I'm kinda pissed that Ryan
was so naturally good at this
because I really wanted to beat him today,
but I'm also glad that he
maybe found a new calling.
- This is something that I would do
probably multiple times a week.
Cause you're just climbing shit, it's fun.